comme chaque dimanche l'émission 7 à 8
propose une interview particulièrement
marquante et dimanche dernier cela n'a
pas fait exception de l'inceste au
meurtre bt match et raconte sa descente
aux enfers
cette fois ci c'est bête humaine chez
une femme victime d'inceste qui a
accepté de témoigner à l'occasion de la
sortie de son livre ce n'était pas de
l'amour
une confession frontale mais très forte
qui a beaucoup touché les
téléspectateurs on pensait qu'on est
juste un animal en est complètement
confusion et y raconte son calvaire
lorsqu'elle a été victime de son père
entre ces 8 et ses 18 ans je me souviens
juste qu'ils me déshabille qui met dans
l'eee elle parle aussi de l'abandon très
douloureux de sa mère qui a ignoré la
souffrance qu'elle partage avec sa soeur
virginie elle aussi victime quand vivre
ensemble comme un couple un père
monstrueux qui a été jusqu'à mettre
enceinte sa propre fille avant de la
tuer tes tiré deux balles à ma soeur
comme il avait toujours dit qu'un jour
ce serait comme ça et comme ça un
témoignage bouleversant qui permet
d'éveiller les consciences sur ce
terrible fléau
et notamment dans ceux dans ce portrait
est là à parler de sa mère et qu'elle
dit ça rend encore tout ça plus au total
six de ses 106 ans et capitaine encore
plus regardés on a très peur de notre
père c'est quelqu'un de très violents et
très puissant on est pétrifié par cet
homme-là et aux violences vont s'ajouter
les viols d'abord virginie votre soeur
aînée puis vous la première fois vous
avez quel âge je dois avoir 8 ans je me
souviens juste qu'ils me déshabille mais
dans l'eee mais ce qui m'a le plus
marqué c'est que la porte s'est ouverte
et c'était ma grande soeur et que
fait-elle mais on a attendu que ma mère
reviennent et elle lui a dit ce que papa
me fait il le fait aussi à betty et
votre maire réagit comment je suis pas
ton mais la table les pions mais la
table c'est tout votre mère ne dénonce
pas votre père non il ne le fera jamais
incroyable oui j'ai été profondément
bouleversé par ce témoignage parce que
je ne sais pas ce qu'il peut y avoir
comme perversité dans dans l'esprit de
cet homme pour agir comme un monstre
comme ça avec ses enfants et en plus qui
m'a encore plus choqué c'est que la mère
elle même était complice des agissements
cédé 0,6 monte le son mari vous savez
que visiblement c'est des choses qui
arrivent plus et oui c'est ça qui est
terrible et du coup j'espère que c'est
un c'était un reportage essentiellement
trait sadi aux victimes de comportements
incestueux de comportements inappropriés
qu'il faut qu'il parle et qui dénoncent
son beau nom mais c'est surtout alors
justement une question audrey omar al va
le faire un vrai travail pour havas
travail et d'accouchement d'interviewer
quand vous tronçon travailler pour le
coup tout sur cette interview là je les
trouvais vraiment je suis désolé je suis
très ému
je les trouvais vraiment bien et j'ai
trouvé dans la délicatesse je pense
qu'elle a passé beaucoup de temps avec
betty pour que betty se sont un peu en
confiance que pour parler ce genre de
choses là croyez-moi il faut il faut du
temps et c'est pas voyeuriste non non on
préfère le témoignage qui est incroyable
lagarde
on va regarder un autre extrait c'est le
moment où on découvre en fait les
pilotes semblant de cette histoire où
finalement le père finit par tuer sa
propre fille et en 2012
vos parents comparaissent pour viol et
violences sur leurs enfants quel est le
verdict ils sont condamnés à 5 ans quand
nous de prison ferme qu'ils ont fait en
préventive docu sont libres deux ans
plus tard en septembre 2014
virginie s'enfuit avec son fils elle se
réfugie chez son patron dans un garage
auto où elle travaille mécanicienne mais
votre père la recherche
il arrive un soir ils tirent sur le
patron et ensuite il a été tiré deux
balles à ma soeur comme il avait
toujours dit qu'un jour un ce serait
comme ça et comme ça et retourne contre
lui est les secours arrivés à ja que
depuis deux vivent en ce moment là il
devient hémiplégique et muet mais il
fait 6 mois dans le coma avant de se
réveiller
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
reconstruction justement il ya une
phrase très forte qu'elle a dit à la fin
de ce sujet c'est je suis une morte
vivante je ne m'autorise pas à vivre
alors que j'ai tout pour
effectivement c'est là on prend la
notion que la mort il ya la mort
physique et la mort psychologique et que
finalement même si aujourd'hui elle a
des enfants etc
on ne peut pas vivre avec ça et claire
il ya une autre chose qui est très dur à
vivre pour elle ça je les ai vus dans
des interviews c'est qu'à l'époque par
amour son avocat celle de sa soeur était
eric dupond moretti et qu'aujourd'hui
qu'elle le voit en tant que ministre de
la justice s'est lui-même parlé de
consentement c'est ça c'est quelque
chose que du coup elle vit au quotidien
parce que voilà qu'il ya toutes les
histoires qui arrive aujourd'hui on voit
que c'est finalement j'irai pas banal
mais c'est quelque chose dont on entend
parler de plus annoncé un ou deux
enfants
il imagine allez c'est pas du tout un
cas isolé c'est pas ma soeur c'est ça il
faut qu'on soit très précautionneuse sur
ce qu'est en train de se passer en
france notamment sur l'âge du
consentement exactes sur le terme de
contentement est sûr et surtout ça parce
que on est en train de passer des lois
ils sont tout simplement scandaleuse et
voilà il faut vraiment il faut vraiment
qu'on soit très vigilant là dessus parce
que parce que il n'ya pas de fans
présents sais pas c'est pas à serrer
c'est pas assez vieux pour eux pour tout
ça c'est un cas pas bravo vraiment 7 à 8
pour tous ces témoignages et celui-là en
particulier qui était absolument
bouleversant
on